so do you tell people you're engineers
or just work in robotics i just say i
work in robotics okay sometimes i'll
just say software developer like
like what do you say you know like when
you get in an uber you don't explain
your whole life because like in japan
uber drivers rarely talk to you oh
really
yeah we don't even have uber yeah oh
yeah that's true yeah no they do no they
do they do but like it's like we have
our own version of uber though yeah yeah
we do we do yeah but yeah no they never
talk they're just like are you having a
nice day and you're like yep and like
okay let's get the temperature okay give
me the idiot five star when i yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'm like
no talking because like i'd see the
memes about oh like the uber drivers
that would like not talk to you and give
them five stars and like in most places
i go to taxi drivers don't really talk
to you at least in the uk like if you
take a black cab they're more likely to
talk to you but if you take a new button
nobody [ __ ] talks i haven't had a
single uber since i got to la that has
talked to me that's crazy yeah some
people all talk to me really yeah
because that's what i hear it's like the
stereotype right right right right right
like they love like starting
conversation getting to know you on the
ride yeah usually like if i don't know
maybe i just give off the aura of like
don't [ __ ] talk to me yeah the moment
i get in they're just like joey all
right
and then they just don't
that like this the sat nav that always
keeps going like drop conor off into and
i'm like whoa that's weird it's singing
we're gonna die
yeah i think on the app they sometimes
it to like the driver's profile it'll be
like excellent conversationalist and
every time i see that i'm like [ __ ]
they're going to talk to me
i ain't going to be able to say [ __ ]
oh because everyone's raided here's a
good tool yeah yeah yeah there's like it
actually has like a little pink speech
100
took us to lax and he is a real estate
agent he picked us up in a [ __ ] like
tesla fully tricked out okay he came up
to us and he's like yeah i do this just
to get clients because he'll only patrol
a rich ass places right and he'll like
just get clients i'll be like yep i am a
wow that's so five here yeah it was
genius it's so genius what the [ __ ] that
was awesome yeah i gotta give you props
by the way because me and connor are
both technically engineers but you've
somehow found a way to be a content
creator but still make use of
engineering yeah we still make use of
your engineering degree right i have
engineering degrees yeah really yeah
that's where we're like opposites i
don't have an engineering degree well
no no i don't were you serious yeah you
went to university though no i went to
well i went to one year of university
and then dropped out because it's all
right
well i i've always said this but doing
an engineering course makes you realize
that you don't want to be an engineer
yeah because it's just boring it sucks
something yeah especially at like
university type thing
everyone thinks are you going to be in
the lab all the time doing stuff i was
in front of a pc math yeah doing math
lab and simulations for just hours
it's like an engineering software that
specializes in like maths and equations
programming language pretending to be
like a really actually useful
programming yeah no one uses it for
anything yeah the problem is like like
usually you should be taught stuff that
you will use outside but it's not useful
outside of the degree so you'd think
that in the degree oh it will help me
learn faster no it makes you learn
slower and shittier it's like it's it
has zero how do they use it
that's just what they've always heard
why do schools do a lot of the things
that's true
so like i guess like that that's really
interesting so you don't have your
energy your engineering degree so did
you make your content to make
engineering fun because i i feel like
you were one of the first is like you
know to us engineering engineering was
always boring but watching your videos
you've somehow made the process of
engineering look [ __ ] fun well it was
like really boring like i did have like
a real job in it yeah and doing software
development for like the uh the state of
hawaii and that was very boring
and i learned it in like a very fun way
and then that made it boring so i wanted
to do like fun projects yeah like make
it better so i actually had like a bunch
of [ __ ] that i made before doing youtube
and i made something and i was like oh
this would be funny to put on youtube
and then yeah that's how that happened
yeah so it was kind of like to make it
more fun for myself right because that
passion was [ __ ] dying quickly at the
job yeah instantly man if you've
probably if you finish the degree you
probably wouldn't be doing this right
now
[ __ ] no man it just felt like it was
never applicable to anything like they
were making us apply for jobs and i was
applying for this job and they were in
the interviews they were asking me
questions i was just like am i supposed
to know this [ __ ] like what
i mean so obviously they would ask you
to explain like engineering concepts and
stuff yeah yeah the times would ask you
to explain something and you're like i
don't even like know what that is
and then i look like a [ __ ] clown
yeah i've had my fair share of clown
interviews you drive like two hours you
wait you you wear a suit that you don't
really know what the [ __ ] you're doing
with you get there and just some old man
grills you and you feel like you're
humiliated yeah yeah what uh what are
your
parts of engine mechanical both i did
mechanical he did like electronic and
electrical engineering yeah i mean like
i get the interview thing uh i draw i
drew a dick in one of my interviews uh
because i applied for a music missile i
applied for a missile company and uh i
ended up uh on earth like unknowingly
drawing a dick and i didn't realize
until the end of the interview of course
i didn't get it
uh and then elon musk stole your design
[Laughter]
did you so i guess like did you quit
your engineering degree for youtube i
mean after all oh no um i i didn't even
get far into the engineering degree like
it was just one year um it was like a
python introductory course right and so
i like was
i like went to college for engineering
but i had to pay for it like with my job
that was already doing engineering yeah
and it was like this that doesn't make
any sense yeah i'm learning to pay you
yeah i paid to learn so i can work in it
and it's like i already got the job uh
yeah and the class like was you know is
like an intro thing they wouldn't let
you do any kind of like testing out of
it or anything right so it's like this
is a variable that's good
um so it just started it also sucked
having to do like a bunch of classes
that had nothing to do with it that is
engineering so yeah i feel like they
have to fluff it out they're like yeah
yeah you need to learn how you know the
project like the like line will work and
it's like well i mean i mean like i
guess yeah even before that like having
to take like an english basic english
word they did that yeah yeah because
it's like a it was oh yeah right you
guys went in the uk right yes yeah yeah
yeah uk it's all done in three years
yeah yeah oh yeah so it's all pretty
like yeah like pretty like full-on here
it's like turbo fluff yeah if you're not
going to an engineering specific school
right um so like a general education
school that i went to the worst school
ever northern arizona university [ __ ]
you northern arizona
um i pissed on that sign when i went
back through there
with my dog uh
yeah it was uh so you i was in like a
like
ancient chinese history and i was like
this doesn't make sense i remember like
this is amazing in an engineering degree
in an engineering degree they make you
take liberal studies as well yeah i know
you're paying to do engineering yeah
yeah because like you need those to get
into the higher level engineering
degrees
like the classes it's [ __ ] stupid
it's crazy yeah it's actually insane
what does anyone study in america
they can go to good schools and stuff i
went to a like a pretty the reason i
went to this one was because they had
like a 90 acceptance rate i had some bad
grades in high school right fair enough
yeah but i mean you know the whole
grades equal intelligence thing is all
kind of weird anyway and yeah yeah
arbitrary but there's you know who's
going to make a better system yeah so
are you most like mostly like
self-taught now with some yeah mostly
for like
for soft yeah for all of yeah mostly
self-driving well you've heard of
engineers you don't need an engineering
degree anymore to do engineering right
google
youtube yeah honestly that's like google
and youtube tutorials just like that
that taught me more in my engineering
degree than my [ __ ] lectures
yeah i'm not going to [ __ ] laugh
is that one uh like the indian people on
like khan academy
dude if they don't have an accent you're
not learning good for real it's a bad
tutorial
those [ __ ] have put up like
five hour tutorials too for free it's
like holy [ __ ] and it's all like
concerning it's all yeah it's always
there's no fluff no [ __ ] they get
right to the point i don't know how they
learn to teach so well yeah but they do
they do
i just think that like the the
universities they're like hey you need
to fill this many hours so just make
[ __ ] up just like that yeah just just
start dragging stuff out i had one guy
and um he
i think this guy because obviously the
teachers they also get graded on how
good they're teaching right yeah yeah so
it was a notoriously hard module it was
just dynamics yeah which is just like
anything i guess yeah and a lot of
people failed the year before so they
brought a new teacher and this guy
clearly just did not give a [ __ ] he was
just there for the paycheck because at
the end of the course he's like come to
my revision lessons yeah you better come
to it you're not going to want to miss
it
and so we were like all right
yeah it was like all right okay cool so
we go up and he literally just just goes
through the exam that's coming up in a
week but just with different questions
just different numbers right he just
goes through it in order yeah oh my god
and so the first time that happened that
you know maybe some people turned up the
second time he did it everyone showed up
yeah yeah because they knew it was
happening it's literally just a cheat
sheet yeah it was [ __ ] that's great it
was fun
you got some professors that are like
because like that are obviously there
for like the research side of like new
university they're working on different
projects yeah because they cannot
lecture for [ __ ] yeah
it's kind of like they only do it
because it's like a contractual
obligation yeah you know i'm researching
some cool projects but you've also got
to lecture some students and you can
always tell because they like speak from
like a different [ __ ] dimension you
know they they they talk to you like
you're already like a professor great
level yeah like level of knowledge yeah
so it's it's like a really like like
you're not conversing with a human no no
no no right yeah so it's like really
hard to find good professors because
it's hard to get one that does both yeah
who like knows what they're talking
about and there's a good teacher yeah
because like some of the smartest
professors you meet just uh the worst
teachers right yeah yeah